the sequence a is defined using this
formula a n is equal to 4 n plus 1 and
we have been asked for the common
difference of the sequence you get a
maximum of 5 seconds to answer this
question it should have taken you just
one second yes just one just by looking
at the sequence we can say that the
common difference D is equal to 4 in an
arithmetic sequence the coefficient of n
is the common difference n is the term
number another way in which we can find
the common difference is by finding the
first few terms the first term will be a
1 its value will be 4 times 1 plus 1
that is 5 the first term of this
sequence is 5 similarly the second term
will be 9 and the third term will be 13
the sequence will be 5 9 13 and so on
and you can see that the common
difference is 4 but in your competitive
exams this method would be too
time-consuming anyway let's try out
another sequence problem here we are
given the first few terms of the
sequence and we have been asked for the
17th term I give you 5 seconds again
look at the terms in the sequence it is
an arithmetic one as the difference
between two continuous terms is constant
and we know that the nth term of an
arithmetic sequence is given by the
formula a plus n minus 1 times D a is
the first term n is the term number and
D is the common difference
so finding the 17th thumb will be pretty
easy here the first term is 2 as the
term number is 17 we write this as plus
17 minus 1 the common difference is 3
solving this we get the 17th term of the
sequence as 50 you may mark this as one
of your star problems expect to see it
in your exams